Speaker 1: Monkey pox is unfortunately exploding.
New York City has declared a state of emergency,
and the right continues to repeat
homophobic tropes to try to dismiss
this one. Also, I mean, listen, they'll diss
any public health concern. They will dismiss,
if possible, with whatever justification they
can find. With COVID, it was it's the China virus
and it's not really dangerous. And the masks
don't work. And they want to take our freedoms
or whatever with monkey pox. It's basically it's
a gay disease. It's a gay sexually transmitted
disease. This is what they're going with, because
it appears as though the very early handful of
cases were in gay men. And of course, it has gone
well beyond that now. And it's, quite frankly,
an incredibly irresponsible distraction to
be focusing on that. But we will get to that.
So a bunch of different things going on. Daily
Beast Report It may be too late to stop monkeypox
becoming endemic in the U.S. and Europe. We failed
to get on top of the monkeypox outbreak, and we
may have missed the chance to stop the disease
becoming endemic and a permanent threat in the
U.S. and Europe. Monkeypox is spreading fast all
over the world, especially in the United States
and Europe, with cases doubling every two weeks,
there's a growing risk that monkeypox will become
a permanent problem in countries where before
outbreaks were rare and small. The proxies, in
other words, close to becoming endemic and a lot
of new places. If this happens, it might become
very difficult to eradicate monkeypox causes. A
fever and rash is fatal in a small number of cases
will become yet another disease that
people have to worry about all the time.
There are two paths to endemic city. If the virus
infects enough people fast enough to outpace
efforts to trace transmission and vaccinate, it
could become endemic in people. The good news is
that this kind of endemic city doesn't have to be
permanent. It's hard, but possible to reverse it.
But Monkey Pox was originally a zoo Nordic animal
virus that circulates in rodent and monkey species
in West and Central Africa, where outbreaks in
humans are frequent. If the pox finds a new home
in some animal species in North America or Europe
could be squirrels, rats or prairie dogs. It will
be all but impossible to eradicate regionally.
Meanwhile, New York City has declared a monkeypox
state of emergency. Mayor Eric Adams has
declared a state of emergency due to monkeypox.
The city estimates 150,000 people, mostly
men who have sex with other men, are at risk.
The city has more than 1200 reported cases,
about 25% of all the cases in the U.S.,
and continues to see the numbers rise. In
terms of the vaccines the city is facing a
shortage of monkeypox vaccines with appointments
filling up minutes after they're released. The
city expects to get 80,000 monkey pox vaccine
doses in the coming days. Now, there are some,
like Marjorie Taylor GREENE and others who are
mocking the entire thing, calling it a scam,
saying it is a sexually transmitted disease
that only threatens a specific group of people.
She says, Laugh at it, market reject it.
Speaker 3: Of course, monkey pox is a
threat to some people in our population. But
we know what causes it, and that's pretty much
it. It's basically a sexually transmitted disease.
So it's not a threat to to most of the population.
And so it's not a global pandemic. It's
really not. And people just have to
have to laugh at it market and reject it.
Speaker 1: This is exactly how COVID. To
some degree, COVID much more contagious
became what it did. I mean, remember,
Matt Gaetz laughed at it early in the pandemic.
Matt Gaetz put on this enormous gas mask
and went on the House floor and it was
all a big joke. And then we know how that
all went. And if this is only a sexually
transmitted disease that affects gay men,
why do kids now have it? Well, it was only a
matter of time. It was only a matter of time.
It spreads through contact of all kinds. And
if an adult who's infected picks up their kid,
their kid can end up with monkeypox. So this
is a very serious situation, not a shock
that Republicans are again laughing off another
public health concern. Will they ever learn?
Find me on Twitter at Pacman and let me know.
We're going to take a very quick break. Much
more coming up today. Glad you're with us. Listen,
I don't know what other shows you watch. I don't
know what other shows you listen to. But this
program is a little different from some of those
others. We actually are primarily funded by our
audience. Now, I know the right wingers love to
email in and say, Oh, it's George Soros that's
funding you. Or It must be the Democratic Party or
whatever. That is very much not the case. Oh, the.
Speaker 4: Bonus show where you
want to make money.
Speaker 1: Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is back.
Well, part of that is true. The bonus show is
one of the perks of membership. I would love
for you to sign up at join Packman dot com and
you can use the coupon code big voting 22 to get
yourself a tidy little discount off of membership.